president biden is considering a
controversial new executive order
that would force public companies to
report how much they pollute and the
global warming risks that they face
climate envoy john kerry says this could
have a major impact on financial
on on financial corporations and the
fossil fuel industry let's take a listen
it's going to change allocation of
capital
suddenly people are going to be making
evaluations considering
long-term risk to the investment based
on the climate crisis
um so dana i want to start with you so
john kerry is sort of making this point
around
why corporations need to sort of report
their fossil fuel and at the same time
wall street is sort of saying
that they're encouraging their investors
to make less
climate risk decisions so how does that
sort of square with the fossil fuel
industry
who's saying that you should invest in
us the fossil fuel industry will
probably have the last laughs when
everybody comes running to them saying
actually could you please still supply
us because we can't turn the freaking
lights on
um i think that is that
dana there are kids watching i know
you're watching greg
i'm not worried about you um so
i think that they do this in europe i'm
pretty sure because it feels like
this whole climate piece is wanting to
make us more like europe but here's what
happens
europe doesn't meet its obligations they
don't they don't
and they just are like oh yeah sorry
yeah we yeah we can't do that
china is not meeting any of its
obligations and no one's going to force
them to do it
i actually don't mind the fact that
there are
ideas in the venture capital world or in
financial management
that have said we're going to be looking
for clean energy investments and that's
what we're going to fund
that's a market signal to me this
basically is just more
uh penalizing of these companies however
who are these companies going to turn to
i mean at this point you know they're
going to want they're going to need
republicans to help them deal with
the coming corporate tax hikes something
like this and increase
regulations but they might not have too
many friends
at the end of this so when john kerry
goes to china and says we are going to
hold your feet to the fire
that's when i think american companies
can think about doing this as well
so i guess my next question goes to you
then katie so in a world where we don't
want to use regulation to encourage
companies to not
emit as much carbon or whatever how do
we do it how do we incentivize companies
to sort of think about the environment
when they're making their corporate
decisions
well john kerry could lead by example
and maybe not
fly private and reduce his own carbon
footprint if he's going to lecture
everybody else about their carbon
footprint outfit
but for him it hasn't changed his
behavior at all even though he's
claiming that climate change is the
greatest threat to the entire world when
it comes to
the challenges that we face and the
bottom line is that okay
you can tax companies and force them to
admit to their
you know so-called pollution but what
they're going to do if this is a cost to
them is simply pass it down to the
consumer which means more expensive
plane tickets for
the average person which only hurts
people who are middle class or poor
people
as these government top-down policies
always do
so companies have an incentive to
compete and to
be clean and they don't want to
necessarily especially in the united
states
but china is not telling their companies
that they can't pollute and that's who
we're competing against
and yet they're punishing the little guy
in america if they decide to go through
with this
sure so uh so jesse same question to you
how do we provide incentives to
companies to do this so we don't have to
put regulations on them and push that
down to the consumer
i think natural gas is the answer
richard if you really want to reduce
emissions get behind clean
abundant domestic natural gas
the shale revolution is actually what's
reduced u.s emissions
not solar panels not teslas so why
aren't the democrats
backing natural gas oh that's right
because they want to control the private
sector and dominate your life that's
the real reason are some of these
companies going to sign up for the shame
game
sure they'll just write it off as good
pr if they're woke and green
it'll get the politicians off their
backs and they'll look the other way
they get rich off chinese slave labor
that's a whole other story but
richard i don't even believe the climate
science anyway they've been wrong for
decades
all these climate scientists said that
manhattan was going to be underwater
there was going to be a worldwide famine
all the arctic ice caps were going to
melt and
you know i was going to be sunburned for
the rest of my life it just hasn't
happened
i have a great tan and and people are
obese there's no famine anywhere so
why do we keep listening to people that
are so wrong
over and over again i mean would you
listen to a
financial advisor that was wrong every
single day
no you'd go broken bankruptcy
we'll agree to disagree on that but greg
you get the final word
quickly climate alarmism is joe's fossil
fuel
we uh we were we were fed a big lie that
he was uh
this centrist this unifier but he's just
greta thundberg
jacked up on ensure and and and he
doesn't
he doesn't even care but i'm gonna go to
i'm gonna uh
return to dana's earlier point uh where
she was rarely
uh uh i mean she was very cogent rarely
cogent
um we're going to have to go there's a
realignment going on
and the realignment is also kind of
hitting the idea of energy i think we're
going to start looking at seeing
democrats and progressives
because a lot of progressives are
changing their mind about nuclear energy
and you're seeing it i think even aoc
has kind of like
warmed warmed to that but um right now
it
this is just another issue where it
becomes a moral crusade
and it's like the church of the almighty
apocalypse if you don't report your sins
then you're evil and i think
corporations will report their sins
because it's just easier to do that than
be you know humiliated on twitter
i i hear that well we will report our
sins in the fastest coming up next